this is raw sewage released by water
companies into our rivers and seas
it's a constant threat whenever sewage
systems become overwhelmed during heavy
rain literally everything that is
flushed down the toilet is ending up
within the rivers it's frustrating I'm
appalled because 90 of all my filming
with sewage related issues is all done
in minimal rainfall or dry weather we
are not talking exceptional rainfall
sewage was released into England's
waterways an average of 825 times a day
last year the worst offending company
was the northwest's United utilities
which was responsible for more than 69
000 spills at the moment the maximum
finer company can be given is 250 000
pounds the government wants to make
those penalties Unlimited
the money would go towards a new fund
dedicated to water restoration
effectively making the polluters pay for
the damage they're causing labor say
those plans don't go far enough this is
just a flimsy Next Step from the
government what we need is a strong plan
mandatory monitoring so we know exactly
where this is happening automatic fines
are making sure those that are
responsible are held to account
since 2015 the government has fined
water companies over 150 million pounds
but the practice of pumping out raw
sewage continues
this Brook in Berkshire is currently at
risk the storm overflow system near here
has been open and discharging material
for 10 days the concern amongst
residents is that could mean sewage
getting into a stream where they fish or
bring their dogs to swim this local
councilor is concerned about the
government's plans you can have whatever
level of final penalty you like but
unless the prosecutions are happening
what
what's the point of having a London
limit to find if you don't actually
prosecute if you don't actually take
action
the group that represents water
companies says they must have the means
to improve sewage systems we're open to
the principle of regulators having the
powers and tools that they feel they
need to deal with the small minority of
cases where there are breaches the rules
which we have to bear down on straight
away of course they're never acceptable
and of course a regulator needs to feel
empowered to deal with that but
fundamentally the thing that will
transform our rivers in the way that the
public expect is going to be investment
and action even if penalties become
easier to pursue and more painful for
the companies there are concerns about
how sewage spills are monitored in the
first place which is by the way either
companies themselves
public outrage over pictures like this
is forcing the government to crack down
on the polluters but this problem needs
bigger solutions to stop this from
happening at such scale Becky Cottrell
Sky News Berkshire